you may have seen this trend on the
internet lately these weird tricky audio
tests where some people hear one word
other people hear another word like last
week everyone's talked about this
there was Yanni versus Laurel check it
out yummy
okay bye applies who heard Yanni okay
bye applause who heard Laurel yeah okay
yeah what about you Andy
I heard Laura yeah yeah it's a very
weird phenomenon there was another one
where people heard either green needle
or brainstorm depending on what
frequency you hear best well today
there's a new one going around some
people hear hop scotch others hear
paddleboat I'll play it listen hopscotch
okay I definitely for me I heard
hopscotch now let's play it again for
Andy okay you're funnier than Conan
Andy did you hear hop scotch - yeah I
definitely wasn't getting hop scotch
okay okay maybe if you focus on the
beginning part of the word you'll hear
it differently let's try it again
hopscotch okay now once more for Andy
Andy you should be hosting the show
instead of that insufferable sack of
nervous tics so Andy what do you hear
that time I'm still not getting
hopscotch so so what are you hearing
paddle boat yeah I guess something like
that it's Rory we're okay concentrate on
the word hopscotch now see if you can
trick your brain into hearing it play it
again Billy you know Andy you could
murder a Conan and make it look like an
accident a little bit of rat poison in
his coconut water no one would ever find
out just spitballing here
so why Andy what you hear that hopscotch
I don't want to do this anymore come on
everyone's doing it this is fun right
everybody
fascinating how we're all hearing the
same thing completely different okay one
last thing about hopscotch Andy we'll
play it for you okay one last time with
hop scotch go ahead on second thought
there have been so many advances in the
field of forensic science your chances
of getting away with murder are
incredibly slim Andy maybe you should
just suck it up and keep collecting that
nice big paycheck for an hour of
ass-kissing a day find your happiness
outside of work take up a hobby spend
more time with your kids it could be
much worse you could be Conan's wife
[Applause]
you better what started
you